you're somebody who her entire career
was built around making your body look
as aesthetic as possible and I think
that you purposely compete in the
category that optimizes for like actual
aesthetic mixed with muscularity and so
on and so forth and yeah men got the
best end of the deal getting to look at
women's bodies than the other way around
even the most curated cut well-honed
male physique we got the better end of
the deal getting to look at women they
get to look at us and I'm sure it's nice
but like compared to yeah just the
female form is way more nice to look at
yeah for sure but like the people and
bodybuilder deserve to see freaks though
they'd rather see the men's bodybuilder
who looks like freaked in the woman's
bodybuilder you know that's true we're
talking about man versus women and
following an attraction and everything
yeah we do a bodybuilding show and you
ask what would you rather look at on
stage right now most of the cowboy men
almost all the characters they'd rather
watch the men on stage